and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review the lego
movie oh my god this is a greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
Lego Mike spoilers okay so I was
originally gonna have a bunch of little
Lego figures doing this review but
surprisingly they're all sold out in
light of the movie so uh I just had to
adapt with whatever I can find in mr.
McCree Dick's office
oh my god this movie is absolutely
incredible here makes me want to hold
out my hands which is in this circular
motion while with the critic evident
that oh yeah okay so I'm gonna put this
away because it's sticky and hairy it
makes me think of scenarios with the
critic I don't want to think about what
viruses they go Nate Emmett a few weeks
of every morning singing a song that
sounds like the second first directing
ball Jamie like a breaking ball cuz
everything is awesome
Teiresias those four chords the exits of
Austin talked about it quickly but then
this female Lego comes in called wild
style ironic because she looks like the
missing member of wild stallions and she
tells him that she is not like everybody
else he is the chosen one which makes
him specifically unique despite the fact
that he's a cliche that's been in every
movie ever made as well as the wise old
man the evil corporate guy the tough
chick the secondary villain who become a
good guy by the end and a giant device
they'll destroy everything I can see why
everybody's calling this the most
original movie of the year
don't Lee travel to all these different
worlds that makes me want to play with
some kind of toy for some reason Lincoln
Logs I think and they discover that
Emmet is a special dog he's just an
ordinary guy I was an ordinary guy once
weird is better but they're stuck with
him because a piece is stuck with him
this is called the mystical piece of
resistance it sounds a lot like a French
term margarita and apparently this piece
is the only thing that can save the
world but it's also the only thing that
can destroy the world kind of like mad
but Amy discovers that his secret power
is that he has no secret powers his lack
of creativity is unpredictable which
means they can come up with the perfect
unpredictable plan to sneak into the
totally predictable place that is always
predictable this movie makes no goddamn
sense but it looks unbelievable you
watch it just to see a really incredible
really long really amazing commercial
it's like the Super Bowl if they cut out
that pesky game though the game this
year was pretty funny too so they have
all these other various Lego characters
like Lego Batman and Lego who the hell
cares because Lego Batman is in this
movie and he has a brief scene with Lego
Billy Dee Williams and Lego not Harrison
Ford come on Harrison Ford you can do it
Josh Hartnett movie but not this was it
any more demeaning than surviving in the
fridge or less demeaning so Lego ma
Batman wyldstyle and morgan freeman
twitter tried to sneak inside this giant
fortress and discover the evil business
man's plan he wants to phrase the world
have you looked outside this winter it's
pretty much frozen and currently living
in a water fountain that's now an igloo
and glue is exactly what he wants to use
to freeze everybody but em it won't let
it happen so he travels to the end of
the universe and comes out on the other
side it's kind of like 2001 a Space
Odyssey only this blows your mind in a
way you can show your kids filled is the
only Kubrick movie that doesn't have a
boob or nipple well unless you count
hell
Johanna comes out to the other side of
reality and what does he discover he was
a child's play toy the whole time oh my
god is the ending to st. elsewhere again
quick hide how he meant out he was
impressively be too serious for this
movie it turns out she belongs to a
family of Jew fros they have a problem
with her Lego the father was to keep his
incredible Lego collection that he has
built all his own untouched while his
little son just wants to play with him
havin adult children taught him anything
toys are meant to be played with her
supposed to be kept in their original
packaging I like to be looked at and
never played with I like how this was
played with him but so the little nigga
one image starts to move because
apparently the kid's imagination is so
strong he created life and his kind of
God I created life it was kind of God
once it just raised too many questions
and any shows the boy and his father
that they can come together and just
play with their toys suing me and me
live happily ever after every product
placement the world was represented and
I'm satisfied because they finally
showed a realistic portrayal of Legos no
seriously they talked to me and the best
thing is millions of children around the
world will now think that they can make
movies with stop-motion Legos until they
realize two minutes in that it's really
boring to do and then they'll just take
him up there news I start to Legos up my
no away no isn't that be infant tired I
just melted them in smoke them they
taste like a life wasted
this is jittery boom saying typhus
somebody take that oh god I don't want
to be in the same room with it please
somebody take this we did his weight
stuff on her head is in her hair
you